two times well nice to meet you will how
are you this place is freaking beautiful
man
thank you tell me more about your place
yeah so this is a project that we got
started on about ten years ago but we've
been working on buying this property for
over thirty years you've been you've
been eyeing a property for thirty years
yeah it wasn't until 2008 with the
downturn of the economy that we heard
that this property is coming on the
market and we the rest is history
yeah more or less the land is the most
important thing that you can have so we
actually have all three geologic
formations that are on planet Earth
sedimentary volcanic and metamorphic all
in one place
each geologic formation brings something
different out in the wine so tell me
what the experience here is like what is
the cost if someone wants to come out
here go on a tour enjoy some of your
most expensive wine it's 200 hours of
person for a tasting okay now do you
allow people to uh help with the making
of that process like you know I heard
about being able to step on grapes and
stuff like that is that possible or
anywhere around here do you know
[Music]
we don't do it here so it's $200 a
person and you take walk-ins anybody can
come be do you have the reserves it's by
appointment in general it's about a
two-year wait if you're interested in
buying what do you mean we don't make
very much
what do you mean look at this what are
you doing if you're not making wine I'm
confused we sell out of it pretty
quickly and we have a waitlist and I
want to skip the line on that two-year
well I think we can do something about
that I think we can all right
a man will I have to know how much was
something like this place this facility
what would this run your rich-ass dead
you know the the land the Napa Valley is
not inexpensive you know you can make
wine and not own the land you can even
produce a wine and not have a winery the
soil is one of the most important things
we have nice warm days but then really
cool evenings you know I actually never
thought I was gonna be in the family
business that that we try and be
strategic about the the way that we
invest in problem so it's a pretty
unique spot you went to college actually
in Berkeley and an incredible community
we really only make one wine I can't get
into hard numbers but if you look up
what 80 acres of really good vineyard
land in that valley comes out to already
looked it up it's roughly between eighty
and a hundred and fifty million dollars
so get a load of that rappers yeah he'll
rapid drinking liquor they make fun of
me god yeah I have red wine conversation
with the sparkles and everything too
right check it out yeah let's going
little little tour after you okay so so
we're here this is where you know most
of the magic happens right so tell me
what you got in these jugs containers we
have a few different tanks here so this
is where all the fermentation happens so
you know sugar and alcohol this is where
all really the magic happens do I want
to know how do you make wine so
basically you know harvest happens from
early September all the way to you know
late October over that time we picked
different parts of the vineyard that are
at different levels of ripeness and
bringing the fruit we do hand sorting
for all of the the clusters and then we
have
a special machine that kind of helps
pick off the berries from the the stems
themselves once that happens we do
another round of hand kind of selection
so we almost go like berry by berry
figuring out which of the right ones to
include in you know in the tanks how
long does it take for a ripe grape to
fully ferment we can have two three
weeks oh really
yeah yeah that's kind of quick right
yeah okay and then the wine goes
downstairs for all the aging that's
where like all them really the
interesting parts happened downstairs
yes what a magic happens so when my dad
was alive he used to do this thing
called a cone liqueur if you ever heard
of that it's this country slang so he
takes like old milk jug when it's over
he cleans it out fills it up with
peaches sis it in the garage for a whole
year and then pours it out the next
Christmas yeah and a lot of people just
be drunk and talking crazy but I guess
we got a similar process we just used
the garage instead of yeah yeah cool
oh so we right here we're at the
fermentation place where most of the
magic happens my next and last question
in here is when do you guys get involved
most of the impact that we have on the
character the wine happens even before
it gets here
got you now we've heard different things
about red wine can you give us a fact
checked on some of these things being
you know a good for I think wine in
general is probably it's probably better
for the soul than anything oh good a
hand sir baby it's better for the Soul
that's all you need to know drink